[Musik]
ein Sommerabend in Bayreuth
[Applaus]
[Musik]
eine Minister schlägt die Wut entgegen
ich
[Musik]
werde geholfen wenn ihr nicht rum
Robert Habeck sucht den Dialog und hatte
schwer gegen eine laute Minderheit
[Musik]
ist nicht einfach aber einfach ist
sowieso nichts in dieser Zeit lösen wir
auch die schweren Probleme meiner
Ansicht nach
[Applaus]
Momentaufnahme aus einem aufgewühlten
Land
seit einem Jahr regiert die
Ampelkoalition sie hatten große Pläne
dann kam der ukrainekrieg es ist eine
physisch seelisch und intellektuell
enorme herausfordernde Zeit ich werde
nachts wach liege dann wach kann ich
wieder einschlafen denke über alles nach
sie wollten den Fortschritt vorantreiben
und sind zu getriebenen geworden
[Musik]
das ist ein Jahr das uns allen viel
abverlangt hat und viel zugemutet hat
ich würde sagen das Motto dieses Jahres
ist es gibt kein Zurück
danke schön es ist eine Zeit der
Zumutungen Energiekrise Inflation
Abstiegsangst
dieses Land hat Reform verpasst die
müssen jetzt nachgeholt werden in
Krisenzeiten ich glaube eine
gesellschaftliche Modernisierung
funktioniert nur mit mehr sozialer
Gerechtigkeit und da kommt die Ampel
einfach nicht voran die Ampel unter
Dauerdruck wir haben ihre
Entscheidungsträger monatelang begleitet
ein Blick ins Innenleben der Regierung
fangen wir verfahrene Situation wir sind
anders nicht rausgekommen gute Arbeit
[Musik]
Abflug vom Regierungsterminal
Robert habe greift nach Warschau es geht
um Öl
seit Putins Überfall auf die Ukraine
droht deutschen Raffinerien der
Stillstand die Regierung sucht
Alternativen zu russischen Öl Polen
könnte helfen etwa mit neuen
importrouten
Warschau Zusagen bekommt ist unklar wie
so vieles in diesen Tagen
sonst fliegt man ja oder fährt man
manchmal irgendwohin und das ist so ein
bisschen ehrlicherweise Alibi und Show
so ist es heute nicht sondern es kann
auch sein dass ich dann sage na ja es
war ein fröhliches Gespräch hier
arbeiten weiter das ist
eine offene Situation
ein grüner als Bittsteller in Sachen Öl
bei einer polnischen Ministerin das
Verhältnis bei der Staaten war jahrelang
belastet jetzt zwingt der Ukraine Krieg
zur Zusammenarbeit Zeitenwende
hat sich komplett verschoben
im dezember 2021 starteten SPD Grüne und
FDP etwas auf Bundesebene völlig neues
die Ampel was eigentlich kaum
zusammenpasst fand eine gemeinsame
Überschrift und versprach sich einen
neuen kooperativen Stil
wir wollen uns etwas zutrauen beim
Klimaschutz beim Umbau unserer Industrie
wir haben während der Verhandlungen Olaf
Scholz neu kennengelernt wir haben in
erlebt als eine starke
Führungspersönlichkeit
Gegensätze können überwunden werden
durch eine lernende Politik das ist das
Versprechen dass wir uns geben
in Warschau bekommt habe ich zusagen in
Sachen Energie die Journalisten im
Presseraum interessiert aber noch ein
anderes Thema
einer Frage an Minister Habeck zur
Tagesaktualität in Deutschland wird ja
viel diskutiert über die Frage ob und
welches schwere Gerät zur Unterstützung
der Ukraine geliefert werden kann wie
stehen Sie dazu diese Dinge müssen ja
genehmigt werden der Kampf denn die
Ukrainer kämpfen ist aus meiner Sicht
ein Kampf für das Völkerrecht für die
Freiheit und für die Demokratie insofern
ist es richtig dass Deutschland auch
schwere Waffen in die Ukraine liefert
schwere Waffen für ein Kriegsgebiet für
die Grünen bislang ein Tabu
ein Jahr zuvor war habe ich in der
Ukraine forderte Waffenlieferungen und
scheiterte damit an der eigenen Partei
jetzt führt er sich bestätigt
raus aber die Schuld die man besser
tragen kann ist der Ukraine im Moment zu
helfen dieses lange nicht entscheiden
wollen das sollte uns nicht zu häufig
passieren die Situation immer noch an
die vor einem Jahr
die Diskussion um Waffen wird sich noch
lange hinziehen
alle ampelpartner müssen sich kurz nach
Kriegsausbruch neuen Realitäten stellen
[Musik]
Carmen in Nordrhein-Westfalen
zu einer Diskussionsveranstaltung hat
sich SPD-Chef Lars Klingbeil angekündigt
die Genossen warten schon auf ihn
bin am ersten 10 69 eingetreten steht
der Steinmeier drin Schröder steht auch
natürlich drin Lafontaine und alle und
jetzt möchte ich ganz gerne auch meinen
jetzigen Vorsitzenden
ja das ist ein Kapitel für sich es tut
mir leid war zum Kaffeetrinken im
Kanzleramt
und jetzt habe ich mir die Hände
gewaschen
Klingbeil verdankt Gerhard Schröder den
Beginn seiner Karriere hat früher für
ihn gearbeitet jetzt ist Schröder das
Schmuddelkind der SPD die gedenkt denn
die SPD-Führung mit unserem naja sagen
wir jetzt so fast schon mittlerweile
Altlast
Ü60 plus
Kollegen umzugehen
putinfan bleiben und uns unser Image
kaputt zu machen spätestens mit Ausbruch
des Krieges hätte ich von Gerd Schröder
erwartet dass sie sich auf die richtige
Seite der Geschichte stellt und es ist
tragisch dass er sich auf die falsche
Seite gestellt hat
Schröder diente SPD als Sündenbock für
ihre langjährige Russland Nähe auch
klingball sie die heute als schweren
Fehler aber man habe ihn nicht allein
gemacht
wir haben die politische Entwicklung von
Putin die letzten Jahre gesehen wir
haben gesehen was er
gemacht hat in Georgien wir haben die
völkerrechtswidrige anjektion der Krim
gesehen und da ist jemand hat sich so
massiv verändert ja seit dem Auftritt
hier auch im Deutschen Bundestag vor 20
Jahren und das hätte man sehen müssen
das gilt aber nicht nur für die SPD
sondern es geht für das politische
System insgesamt und das ist etwas was
mich umtreibt
nicht der SPD zu Russland das ist nicht
nur Gerhard Schröder die Schweriner
Ministerpräsidentin Manuela Schwesig
etwa setzte sich jahrelang für Putins
Pipeline Nord Stream 2 ein mit einer
dubiosen Stiftung auch noch nach der
Annexion der Krim
also ich möchte mich ja ungern in die
Politik der Sozialdemokratie einmischen
werden wir arbeiten im
Verteidigungsausschuss wirklich gut
zusammen das Frau Schwesig immer noch
Ministerpräsidentin es ist bemerkenswert
also es gab Politikerinnen und Politiker
die sind deutlich wegen weniger haben
die den Entschluss gefasst alleine zu
ziehen das wichtige war das Frau
Schwesig als Person die heute noch in
politischer Verantwortung ist und ich
sage auch Gott sei Dank sie ist eine
wichtige Ministerpräsidentin sie ist
erfolgreich gewählt worden dass diese
sofort auch Konsequenzen aus diesem
Krieg gezogen hat und auch gesagt hat da
sind Fehler passiert das auch auf
arbeitet und insofern gibt es da gibt es
da von mir gar keine Kritik und kein
Zweifel an ihrer Person
[Musik]
Kundgebung zum Tag der Arbeit
Pflichttermin für spd-generalsekretär
Kevin Kühnert
Gewerkschaften und Friedensbewegungen
stehen sich schon immer nah für kühne
wird es jetzt in Kriegszeiten zum
Problem
[Musik]
den Kummer hat ihm sein Kanzler
eingebrockt drei Tage nach Kriegsbeginn
hatte Scholz eine Partei überrumpelt mit
der Ankündigung eines Sondervermögens
100 Milliarden Euro extra für die
Bundeswehr vorher und denkbar für die
SPD
wir erleben eine Zeitenwende
und das bedeutet die Welt danach
ist nicht mehr dieselbe wie die Welt
davor
bei Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
dagegen zeigt sich Schulz zögerlich
[Musik]
vielen in der SPD gefällt diese
Zurückhaltung beim Waffenexport auch
diesem ehemaligen Bundestagsabgeordneten
ja
was ich für die Arbeit brauchte
was wir im Jahr 2022 gemerkt haben ist
dass so groß der Wunsch nach Frieden und
nach Ausgleich und nach Verständigung
sein mag dass wir bei manchmal auf eine
Wirklichkeit treffen die dem einfach so
gar nicht entspricht und dass man nur
durch
beschwören daran auch nichts ändern kann
und so würde ich gerne auch begreifen
dass sehr Einzelfall bezogen wir schauen
müssen was das Richtige und auch der
deutschen Geschichte angemessen Vorgehen
ist
oh schön haustürwahlkampf
Nordrhein-Westfalen steht im Mai 2022
kurz vor einer Landtagswahl
hi schönen guten Tag ist mein Name von
der SPD ich möchte Generalsekretär von
der SPD ich habe gehört es gibt essen da
bin ich direkt vorbeigefahren
und weiter geht's hallo
wir sind die SPD
die Bundesregierung hat gerade ein
energiegeld von 300 Euro beschlossen
Kühnert will mehr Geld für Entlastungen
dafür die Schuldenbremse lösen doch in
der hängt die FDP
warte mal im
[Musik]
jahresheizung ja jetzt 300 Euro hin oder
her das werden nicht die letzten Hilfen
gewesen sein die geleistet werden müssen
ich glaube nicht persönlich dass wir
jetzt noch dreieinhalb Jahre in der
Regierung es werden durchhalten können
nur die liberale Partei Seele zu
streicheln wenn es um Fragen von
Staatsverschuldung und Steuersystemen
geht vielleicht wird man sich irgendwann
doch mal ehrlich machen und sagen müssen
dass die Herausforderung die uns das
Schicksal vor die Füße wirft sich nicht
an Parteiprogramme der ein oder anderen
Partei halten
ja klar können wir ein Foto machen der
Epochenbruch bringt neue Meinungsführer
hervor Moment ich gehe ein bisschen so
damit wir in der Sonne sind
Marie Agnes Strack Zimmermann ist im
Frühjahr 2022 plötzlich ein prominentes
Gesicht der FDP
die Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses fordert
vehement schwere Waffen für die Ukraine
und treibt den Kanzler vor sich her
ich weiß nicht warum der Kanzler
Probleme hat immer ein Wort das Wort
Panzer in den Mund zu nehmen oder
schwere Waffen ich verstehe es nicht er
hat Führung angeboten und hat gesagt wer
den Welt hat Führung bestellt jetzt
wollen wir die Bestellung aus einlösen
die haben zu führen nicht nur
wirtschaftlich sondern auch militärisch
und für die die diese Rolle nicht
annehmen wollen sage ich dann sitzen sie
womöglicherweise im falschen Moment am
falschen Platz
manche Bürger feiern Zimmermann genau
für diese Kritik am Kanzler anderen geht
sie zu weit
[Musik]
wenn ich jetzt sagen
Mitarbeitern
aber der Unterschied ist der Unterschied
ist der Kanzler ist nicht mein Chef
sondern wir arbeiten zusammen und
diskutieren
doch in der Politik muss man Dinge auch
mal artikulieren welche Führung wollen
die Deutschen
Streik Zimmermann sieht und bedient ein
neues Bedürfnis nach klaren Ansagen raus
aus der Ära Merkel aus der auch Olaf
Scholz stammt
es ist natürlich auch eine typenfrage
darf man nicht vergessen der Kanzler hat
das darf man auch nicht vergessen die
Wahl gewonnen weil er so ist wie er ist
also ruhig bedacht er hat in den
Wahlkämpfen nicht so viel gesagt
und insofern hatte er damit Erfolg die
Leute wollten jemand der ruhig ist der
jetzt nicht so und jetzt jetzt ist
eine andere Situation und jetzt ist der
Stil der ihn ins Kanzleramt gebracht hat
unter Umständen nicht das was jetzt die
Leute wiederum erwarten
am Nachmittag kommt der Parteichef zur
Kundgebung noch ein Tag bis zur
Landtagswahl in NRW
die Umfragen für die FDP miserabel
Christian Lindner ist in Dilemma
vor der Wahl standen seine liberalen für
einen schlankenstaat jetzt ist Krieg und
er Finanzminister muss Milliarden Euro
herbei organisieren
eines muss klar sein auch bei einem
liberalen Finanzminister du kannst nur
das ausgeben was vorher erwirtschaftet
worden ist
Lindner ist zugleich Parteichef und
Bundesminister das Schicksal der FDP hat
er zu seinem Schicksal gemacht ich will
jetzt wie folgt wir dreht mir den Rücken
zu mach den selfie-modus an und dann
schaue ich in die Bildschirme hier so
durch dann haben wir jetzt und hätten
die massenzelt
ohne Wenn und ohne aber
[Applaus]
ich trinke nie ein Bier aber jetzt
trinke ich ihn Bier
so ich würde mal sagen ich bin nicht
enttäuscht worden was immer auch
passiert ich habe einfach so viel
Scheiße schon
Entschuldigung vielen Dank für ihren
Einsatz auf die Freiheit und der Rest
kann uns mal
[Gelächter]
Abend großer Verlierer bei der NRW-Wahl
ist die FDP sie büßt mehr als die Hälfte
ihrer Wähler ein und fliegt aus der
Landesregierung
okay
schönere Abende aber mund abputzen
Christian dürr
fDP-Fraktionschef im Bundestag sitzt in
der Parteizentrale und sucht mit seinem
Team nach satzbausteinen für die
TV-Auftritte
machen nicht das populäre sondern das
Richtige tun und ist dann populär zu
machen
das gehört dazu Teil des Jobs Teil der
Jobbeschreibung
wenn alle immer gewinnen würden bei
Wahlen dann müsste es jetzt mehr als
100% geben wenn alle immer zulegen
besonders schmerzlich für die Liberalen
die Grünen haben zugelegt in den
bundesweiten beliebtheitsumfragen führen
zu dieser Zeit habe und die grüne
Außenministerin
eine Außenpolitik von der auch meine
Frau sagen würde oder sagt ja
also wenn die beiden eine richtig grüne
Politik machen würden dann wären
natürlich nicht das haben
Abrücken von alten Glaubenssätzen wird
im Epochenbruch offenbar belohnt
die FDP aber hält fest an ihrem
Grundsatz Schulden vermeiden
wir wollen zurück zur Schuldenbremse im
kommenden Jahr das hätte es ja bei einer
nichtregierungsbeteiligung der FDP im
Bund nicht gegeben bei jeder anderen
Konstellation wäre die Schuldenbremse
geschliffen worden und von daher zeigt
das schon dass FDP dann erheblichen
Unterschied macht aber das muss man halt
auch deutlich sagen
die FDP hatte befürchtet die Ampel koste
sie Profil
die Angst wächst mit diesem Abend
wer hat eigentlich Zeit sich mit
Umfragen für Parteien zu beschäftigen wo
wir jetzt in dieser Krise sind Menschen
Angst haben um ihre wirtschaftliche
Existenz glauben Sie die Mehrheit im
Land interessiert sich momentan für das
Wohl oder wer einzelner Bundesparteien
ich glaube sie jedenfalls nicht ich sehe
es so wir müssen das Land jetzt
zusammenhalten gut durch die Krise
bringen und dann tritt man irgendwann
wieder vor die Wählerinnen und Wähler
und dann urteilen die
[Musik]
seid die Ölraffinerie im
brandenburgischen Schwedt zur
Betriebsversammlung hat sich Robert
Habeck angekündigt
[Musik]
mit Schwedt steht und fällt die
Kraftstoffversorgung Ostdeutschlands
bisher kommt das Öl aus Russland viele
fürchten jetzt um ihren Job und machen
den Wirtschaftsminister dafür
verantwortlich
Habeck kommt sieht die Distanz
die Ablehnung
und die Chance für ein Symbol
s
ich hoffe bei all dem Ärger den sie über
die Bundesregierung über mich persönlich
vielleicht haben vielleicht sehen sie
auch dass wir es gemeinsam machen wollen
ich würde mich freuen wenn sie mich
nicht mehr als den Feind sehen würden
sondern als jemand der wirklich versucht
diesen Standort zu retten und am Leben
zu erhalten wenn ihr Zukunft zu führen
ich wollte sie nur noch mal höflich
daran erinnern dass sie ein Eigenart
abgelegt haben dass sie geboren haben
ihre Kraft in deutschen Folge zu widmen
und seinen Nutzen zu leben
kurzfristig argumentieren wenn du sagst
ich höre meine Kraft die Immobilien des
deutschen Volkes zu widmen
was kümmere ich denn ich glaube dass das
was wir in der Ukraine erleben ein
solcher Tabubruch in der Friedensordnung
Europas ist dass das nicht
erfolgreich sein darf und wenn das
erfolgreich ist
dann glaube ich der sündige ich mich am
Amtszeit weil damit quasi gesagt wird
dann greift doch das nächste Land an und
dann öffnen wir die Tür zu Krieg zu lang
Krieg in Europa wie wir es vor 200
Jahren hatten
auf die andere Welt
Solidarität zeigen nicht nur auf sich
schauen habe gehofft dass diese
Botschaft einsickert
[Musik]
Warschau Ende Juni ein besonderer Ort
auch in der Geschichte der SPD hier am
Denkmal für die Helden des Warschauer
Ghettos kniete vor mehr als einem halben
Jahrhundert Willy Brandt
der damalige Bundeskanzler und SPD-Chef
setzte mitten im Kalten Krieg auf
Aussöhnung mit dem Osten dafür bekam er
den Friedensnobelpreis
[Musik]
wir müssen der Gewalt und der Androhung
von Gewalt im Verkehr der Staaten
entsagen endgültig und ohne Ausnahme
transaktueller Nachfolger als Parteichef
kommt zum Chef der polnischen
Sozialdemokratie Antrittsbesuch
e
bedroht von Putin und fragen warum hilft
oder Scholz der Ukraine nicht
entschlossene steht der heimlich auf
Putins Seite
beschwichtigt der Kanzler habe doch
immerhin einige Waffen versprochen
Olaf Scholz hat deutlich gemacht dass
jeder Zentimeter des nahtoteritoriums
verteidigt werden wird vom Bündnis das
ist eine ganz wichtige Aussage
nach der Pressekonferenz geht es zum
Denkmal ein pikanter Programmpunkt
Klingbeil hat er ein paar Tage zuvor
eine Rede gehalten die mit der
jahrzehntelangen Friedenspolitik der SPD
zu brechen schien und damit auch mit
Willy Brandt
Friedenspolitik bedeutet für mich auch
militärische Gewalt als legitimes Mittel
der Politik zu sehen das ist stets das
Äußerste Mittel das ist auch klar was
ist eben auch ein Mittel das eingesetzt
werden muss mein Land
ist keine große Macht mehr und kann es
nicht mehr sein
Deutschland muss den Anspruch einer
Führungsmacht haben
viele Genossen sind irritiert
klingball definiert im Alleingang
Deutschlands Rolle neu er will seiner
Partei einen Ruck geben und wohl auch im
Kanzler weniger zögern mehr
Verantwortung
wir haben gerade Krieg gerade in diesen
Minuten werden Menschen umgebracht in
der Ukraine weil Wladimir Putin die
staatlich anerkannten die
völkerrechtlich anerkannten Grenzen
nicht akzeptiert und davor die Augen zu
verschließen und das zu ignorieren das
wäre nicht im Sinne Willy Brandt ich
halte von dem Begriff Führungsmacht
ehrlicherweise überhaupt nicht weil ich
glaube dass er ein völlig falsches
Selbstverständnis beschreibt diese Rolle
darf und sollte Deutschland nicht
einnehmen weder für die Sache weil man
dadurch aus meiner Sicht nichts erreicht
außer Gegenwehr noch in seiner Rolle
die ampelparteien müssen den
kriegsschock verarbeiten zugleich
fordern die Folgen des Krieges schnelles
Handeln steigende Preise Furcht vor
Energieknappheit
damit wachsen die Spannungen zwischen
den Koalitionären
[Musik]
fDP-Fraktionschef Christian Dürr auf dem
Weg zum koalitionsfrühstück die Spitzen
der ampelfraktionen treffen sich jeden
Dienstagmorgen normalerweise in einem
Ihrer Räume
an diesem Tag gab es eine Panne
[Gelächter]
das Catering steht für sehnlich im Saal
der Linkspartei
ausgerechnet
oder bist gestellt die Systemfrage
und Hanna Müller
[Gelächter]
guten Morgen
in der Koalition knirscht es
Grundauffassungen kollidieren
SPD und Grüne fordern neuerdings eine
übergewinnsteuer Geld von
Großunternehmen die mit der Krise höhere
Gewinne machen für die FDP eine maximale
Zumutung
nein also es ist mit uns nicht zu machen
aber ich will sagen in diesen
außergewöhnlichen Zeiten ist es
legitimes zu diskutieren ja wie das
heißt man darf darüber sprechen aber
kommen darf auf keinen Fall man darf
über alles in demokratischen Spektrum
sprechen das gehört zu Demokratie und
zur Politik dazu auch wenn ich
inhaltlich in dem konkreten Punkt nein
sage und sage es wird so nicht kommen es
wird keine zusätzlichen Steuern in
Deutschland geben weil wir steuernland
sind auch die FDP diskutiert jenseits
des Koalitionsvertrags über eine
Laufzeitverlängerung von Atomkraftwerken
die grüne Fraktionsspitze hofft zu
diesem Zeitpunkt dass diese Debatte
schnell versendet
also diskutieren darf man in einer
Koalition finde ich alles aber man muss
zu dem stehen was man miteinander
beschlossen hat das ist wichtig das ist
die Grundlage dafür dass man gemeinsam
arbeiten kann und mit Blick auf die
Atomenergie beispielsweise haben wir uns
klar vereinbart wieder weg ist nämlich
raus
doch die FDP lässt nicht locker
Fraktionschef Dörr wird zum Sprachrohr
für eine akw-verlängerung er betont nur
wenige Kraftwerke nur als Option nur ein
paar Monate es ist der Beginn eines
monatelangen Streits
wir müssen eben auch kurzfristig darüber
reden diese Kernkraftwerke die am 31.12
0 Uhr abgeschaltet werden dass die etwas
länger laufen können auch das muss eine
Option sein
[Musik]
Tag der offenen Tür der Bundesregierung
großer Andrang an Wirtschaftsministerium
der Minister selbst kommt etwas später
als geplant ein Termin im Kanzleramt hat
mal wieder länger gedauert
die Tage des Vizekanzlers sind
vollgepackt Gasspeicher
Wirtschaftshilfen Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren und jetzt auch die
Atomdebatte
[Applaus]
also der Bundesminister für Wirtschaft
und Klimaschutz der hat dieses Hauses
Roboter
entschuldigung dass ich zu spät bin also
wir haben eine gute Zeit auf jeden Fall
ich habe mir gesagt
die Fragen an diesem Tag wohlwollend
freundlich
Harbeck gilt zu diesem Zeitpunkt als
einer der beliebtesten Minister der
Republik das hat viel zu tun mit dem
Stil seiner Kommunikation
er verkündet nicht sondern scheint seine
Gedanken zusammen mit dem Publikum zu
entwickeln erklärt offen seine Nöte auf
viele wirkt das einnehmend habe ich weiß
das
ich habe eine Zeit lang als
Schriftsteller gearbeitet ich habe
Philosophie und Literatur studiert also
der
Kommunikationsstil ist quasi etwas was
ich handwerklich würde ich sagen gelernt
habe aber am Ende müssen die
CO2-Emissionen runter muss der Ausbau
der Erneuerbaren vorangebracht werden
muss die Wirtschaft genug Energie haben
dann müssen die Verbraucherpreise
bezahlbar bleiben und die soziale Frage
in Deutschland gelöst werden und wenn
wir das nicht hinbekommen dann ist das
andere alles nur Geschwätz und Gerede
ich wollte eigentlich nur fragen ob sie
2025 als kanzlerkandidieren kann
die Frage taucht bis zum Sommer immer
wieder auf Alex Antwort er sei jetzt
Minister
das macht sehr gute Werbung für die
Öffentlichkeit rechnet ihm offenkundig
an dass er weite Wege geht auch im
Widerspruch zum eigenen Parteiprogramm
Habeck bittet Katha um Gas eine Regime
das massiv gegen Menschenrechte verstößt
in Deutschland forciert er den Bau von
flüssiggasterminals blitzt
Kohlekraftwerke länger am Netz fossile
Energie klimaschädlich und auch beim
Ausbau der Windenergie gilt mehr Tempo
weniger Rücksicht auf Naturschutz ein
Minister im Geschwindigkeitsrausch
Entschuldigung
mit großer Geschwindigkeit maximale
Geschwindigkeit mit einer ich würde
sagen affenartigen Geschwindigkeit im
Lichtgeschwindigkeit
Lichtgeschwindigkeit wie groß ihre Angst
davor auch ein entscheidenden
inhaltlichen Fehler zu machen
ich habe keine Angst auch im Begriff
keine Angst weil das an Ende am Ende
eine lehmhaltung ist ich würde sagen
Konzentration und eine gewisse
Anspannung die gibt es weil die
Entscheidung eben höchst relevant sind
keine Angst vor Fehlern
auf einer Sommerreise besucht Harbeck
Firmen die viel Energie brauchen zum
Beispiel eine Glasfabrik in Thüringen
Gas ist ihr Lebenselixier doch der
Brennstoff wird jetzt Torrent teuer
noch nicht zu Ende und die schwierigen
Monate liegen vor uns
aber wir als Unternehmen haben
sicherlich mehr Kosten von 100 Millionen
Euro
100 Millionen das Problem im Hintergrund
dem Gas Großhändler Juniper droht die
Pleite ihm fehlt der billige Stoff aus
Russland ohne Juniper kollabiert das
deutsche Energiesystem zur Rettung
verkündet habe ich eine gasumlage höhere
Preise für Privatleute mehrere hundert
Euro im Jahr das ist ein
schwieriger Schritt ein Schritt der
eine hohe Belastung mit sich bringt
deswegen ist es wichtig dass der zweite
Schritt mitgegangen wird dass die
Verbraucher und die Verbraucher an
dieser Stelle muss ich sagen gezielt
entlastet werden
Preiserhöhungen nur für Gaskunden die
dann wieder entlastet werden sollen
alles um ein Unternehmen zu stützen
plötzlich wollen auch andere
energienhändler profitieren bald wird
klar die Umlage funktioniert nicht
wer ist dafür verantwortlich die
Erzählungen gehen auseinander bis heute
es ist immer eine gemeinsame Leistung in
der Regierung wir haben gemeinsam die
gasumlage designt besprochen und auch
beschlossen als Parlamentarier muss ich
nun mal sagen den entsprechenden Brief
mit den Darlegungen zur Notwendigkeit
den habe ich nicht von der
Bundesregierung sondern den habe ich aus
dem Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz bekommen bei Mitleid hält
sich bei Bündnis 90 die Grünen in
Grenzen die Grünen haben im Vergleich zu
den Freien Demokraten derart viel Bälle
in der Luft für die wenn einer
runterfällt sie nicht gescholten werden
da muss er habe jetzt durch gab es
irgendwann mal auch an sie herangetragen
in den Gedanken retten wir doch nur ein
paar gleich mit staatlichen Geld nein
warum nicht gar nicht so
aber das liegt doch nicht doch viel
näher als so eine komplizierte Umlage zu
erfinden ich habe sie nicht erfunden
wer hat sie erfunden
es ist Vergangenheit ihr Interesse das
aufzuarbeiten Mainz nicht
bist du geplanten gasumlage war Habeck
der populärste Minister jetzt bietet er
Angriffsfläche auch für die
Koalitionspartner von mangelndem
Handwerkszeug ist die Rede im Sommer
2022 stürzt habe ab in den
beliebtheitsumfragen auch die Opposition
kritisiert heftig das bringt bei habe
das fast zum überlaufen sein Zorn
entlädt sich an Friedrich Merz
das hören wir von der Opposition und das
ist der eigentliche Punkt die Gasanlage
muss weg sind wir denn hier im
Fußballstadion oder was ist das mit Demo
muss weg sie sind die muss weg auf
Position was ist denn das für eine
Antwort wir haben sehr früh auf die
Probleme hingewiesen die mit der
gasumlage einhergehen Robert Habeck hat
sie nicht ernst genommen hat es
wochenlang versucht mit der Brechstange
herbeizuführen und musste es dann
aufgeben also wenn er etwas aufgeben
muss weil es nicht funktioniert dann
darf er sich nicht darüber beschweren
dass wir es früher gesagt haben dass es
nicht funktioniert am Ende kommt die
glasumlage nicht Juniper wird
verstaatlicht
die Verletzungen innerhalb der Koalition
bleiben
Köln Ende September Fridays for future
hat zum bundesweiten klimastreik
aufgerufen
mit dabei Sarah Lee Heinrich
Ko-Vorsitzende der Grünen Jugend
gehen heute für Klimaschutz
und oh das Video ist richtig geil
geworden checkt nämlich dann kann ich so
meine Story packen
die Demonstrierenden werfen der
ampelregierung vor den Klimaschutz zu
vernachlässigen und
ärmere Menschen im Stich zu lassen auch
Sarah Lee Heinrich findet die Grünen
Kabinettsmitglieder sein zu
kompromissbereit
sei gut dass auch eine grüne Partei
immer daran
interessierung ist nicht schafft die
Gesellschaft zusammenzuhalten dann
bringt uns es auch nichts dass ich die
drei Parteien quasi noch mögen wie
findest du die Ampel
grüne Mitglieder die die eigene Führung
kritisieren das ist inzwischen zur
Ausnahme geworden viele in der früher
sehr diskussionsfreudigen Partei üben
jetzt regierungsdisziplin auch die Grüne
Jugend und kritisiert die alt vorderen
nicht direkt also ich glaube das
Vertrauen an für bei mir an an die
Grünen ist glaube ich
weniger das Problem dass ich nicht
glaube dass sie das nicht auch wollen
ich glaube mein Problem ist eher dass
die sich nicht gut durchsetzen gegen
andere Parteien
für Sarah Lee Heinrich hat die Demo auch
eine ganz persönliche Note für Sie
denken auch die Grünen manchmal zu wenig
an die sozialen Folgen ihrer Politik
meine Mama liegt immer noch ein Hartz IV
gerade und ich bin in Hartz IV
aufgewachsen ich weiß wie das sind ganz
vielen Leuten geht die sich das jetzt
gerade nicht leisten können sich
überhaupt den Wocheneinkauf richtig
leiten zu können die Tafeln sind
überlaufen
also es ist kein Spaß deswegen kann ich
halt die vielen Menschen verstehen die
gerade wirklich enttäuscht von der
ampelregierung sind
[Musik]
ein Mittwochvormittag im Bundestag
Christian Dörr lässt sich die
anstehenden Termine vortragen der
fDP-Fraktionschef ist müde hinter den
Koalitionären liegen lange Tage
Vergleich zu den letzten Wochen Urlaub
irgendwie so nur keine Ahnung und 14
Stunden oder so das ist ja absurd und
dann fühlt sich wirklich wie
mitten in den Ferien
am Wochenende zuvor hat die Ampel ein 65
Milliarden Euro Entlastungspaket
beschlossen es war ein hartes Ringen
warum sind sie denn so müde ja das ist
eine gute Frage was könnte mit schlicht
und einfach zu wenig Schlaf
zusammenhängen
besondere Zeiten erfordern besondere
Schlafrhythmen
die Koalition hatte sich vorgenommen
keine Nachtsitzungen doch die
Meinungsverschiedenheiten sind zu groß
Grüne und SPD hatten ein Aufweichen der
Schuldenbremse gefordert nur mit Mühe
erreicht die FDP dass das nicht passiert
dafür sollen Energiekonzerne abgeschöpft
werden die in der Krise hohe Gewinne
machen das kommt eine übergewinnsteuer
nahe die die FDP abgelehnt hatte
der sieht seine Partei trotzdem nicht
als Verlierer er beharrt auf Feinheiten
das hat mit Gewinnen von Unternehmen gar
nichts zu tun das ist der Grund warum
wir sagen und übergewinnsteuer ist
totaler Quatsch aber an die Erlöser
ranzugehen die mit Marktwirtschaft nicht
zu tun haben dieser löse da muss man als
Staat eingreifen also da greife ich
sozusagen guten Gewissens ein
ungelöst ist noch immer der Streit um
die Atomlaufzeiten
Verlängerung nur als Option für ein paar
Monate so hatte die FDP die Diskussion
begonnen mittlerweile spielt Dirk Chef
das Thema immer größer
zwei Kraftwerke sollen jetzt am Netz
bleiben für mich ist das nicht
ausreichend es geht nicht um einen
Winter den wir jetzt überbrücken müssen
sondern um drei bis fünf Jahre sagt ganz
offen ich bin der Überzeugung wir
brauchen alle Kernkraftwerke auch bis
Streit ums Atom und ums Geld für
Entlastungen die anfangsharmonie
verflogen viele fragen sich wo ist
eigentlich der Kanzler
klar erwarte ich von dem
sozialdemokratischen Bundeskanzler in so
einer Situation auch man Machtwort zu
sprechen es ist ihm ja auch einfach
gefallen sich ins Parlament zu stellen
und zu sagen jetzt gibt es 100
Milliarden für die Bundeswehr das Wort
Machtwort finde ich irgendwie komisch
also das mache ich eher nicht mal zu
Hause was bringt denn das also sich
gegenseitig irgendwas vorhalten absurd
in einer Koalition der Kanzler die
Richtlinienkompetenz so sagt es das
Grundgesetz
doch zu diesem Zeitpunkt sieht es nicht
so aus als ob Scholz diese Kompetenz
überhaupt nutzen will es ist gut dass
ich sie habe aber natürlich nicht in der
Form dass ich jemanden einen Brief
schreibe bitte Herr Minister machen sie
das folgende
die größte Oppositionsfraktion sieht die
Schwäche des Kanzlers und greift an ich
sage Ihnen der Bundeskanzler
Sie diesen Irrsinn aus ihrer Koalition
da bricht es aus Scholz heraus die
Probleme die seine Koalition jetzt löse
habe eine CDU-Kanzlerin im Land
eingebrockt 16 Jahre lang
[Musik]
der letzten Jahre schade von unserem
Land noch heute das waren sie in den
letzten 24 Jahren war die SPD 20 Jahre
mit in der Regierung also da zeigen
mindestens genauso viele Finger auf Olaf
Scholz zurück wir auf uns gezeigt hat
aber irgendwann wird in den Augen der
Öffentlichkeit das nur noch
einigermaßen lächerlich wirken denn die
Verantwortung für den Zustand jetzt und
in den nächsten Zeit den Trichter diese
Bundesregierung und nicht die
Bundesregierung vorher
[Musik]
ich glaube wir sind trotz laufen bringt
das nichts wir müssen uns ein bisschen
aufteilen wahrscheinlich
Niedersachsen es ist das
Heimatbundesland von spd-cheflers
klimberg Landtagswahlkampf
[Applaus]
mittlerweile hat die Koalition weitere
200 Milliarden Euro Entlastungen
beschlossen Kanzler Scholz nennt es
einen doppelwumms doch dankbarkeit ist
kaum zu spüren das Land wirkt erschöpft
und die SPD ratlos
was erwarten die Menschen von einem
Kanzler die Wahlkämpfer bekommen von den
Bürgern widersprüchliches zu hören
ganz oft so nee und geht gar nicht und
Olaf und da geht auch gar nicht und
macht zu wenig Öffentlichkeitsarbeit und
so weiter
so aber so schön dass man euch ist wir
wollen es einfach Bürgermeister
über Olaf Scholz und ähm das ist
manchmal ein bisschen anstrengend sie
wünschen sich auf der einen Seite jemand
der besonnen ist das haben sie ja mit
Olaf Scholz und das sagen sie dann auch
irgendwie im zweiten Satz aber auf der
anderen Seite wollen sie manchmal mehr
Action also was die Leute wollen weiß
ich eigentlich so nicht
einen Kanzler verteidigen der sich kaum
festlegt wie geht das
Klingbeil erklärt Scholz Eigenart zur
Stärke
ich sag euch ich bin froh dass da dass
da keinen inszenierer sitzt das sei kein
Cowboy sitzt dass da kein Haus drauf
sitzt ich bin mir sehr sicher viele
Menschen im Land werden am Ende sagen
Gott sei Dank dass da jemand sitzt der
nicht so ist wie Boris Johnson und Trump
doch auch klimbal merkt Scholz Schweigen
lässt Raum für den Streit der anderen
der SPD-Chef ist zunehmend genervt
ich finde mit diesen Streitereien
Beschluss sein also das trägt ja auch
gerade zu Verunsicherung war ich würde
mir manchmal wünschen man setzt sich an
einen Tisch man findet dann Lösung das
ist jetzt seit Wochen öffentlichen
Streit über die Frage der Atomkraftwerke
gibt das ist kein Zustand der gut ist
doch die Atom Diskussion geht munter
weiter die FDP sieht darin auch die
Chance Profil zu zeigen ihre
Umfragewerte sind schlecht um die 5 %.
in Hannover treffen sich die Liberalen
zum wahlkampfaktionstag auch
fDP-Fraktionschef Christian dürr ist
Niedersachsen
mutmachst selfies mit Parteifreunden die
Ampel hat die FDP in eine
Identitätskrise gestürzt perfekt
wie sie mehr Markt oder mehr soziales
die Antwort ist unklarer denn je
ich habe die Leute gefragt warum sie uns
nicht wählen zum Beispiel Nummer eins
Sozialpolitik wir sind die Partei der
Kälte alle reden
andere Dinge
natürlich interessiert was Menschen aber
nicht soziale Wohltaten sondern ist so
zu machen dass es dass Menschen wirklich
hilft das ja klar
als Chef der unfallaparte
eben sowas von umgefallen
die Alternative die sie haben
nichts machen
wenn die FDP nicht mehr vom Markt steht
so
also
das machen wir jetzt ein bisschen
zuletzt hat die fdp-wahl Niederlagen
erlitten
moin Saarland Schleswig-Holstein NRW und
jetzt in Niedersachsen
dürfe sucht die Stimmung hochzuhalten
irgendwie
darf ich Ihnen Rose mitgeben oder zwei
besser gesagt weil ja
eine zweite Rose schnell eine zweite
Rose und für euch Gummibärchen oder
eine Rose gib mir noch meine Hose
schnell
wie unhöflich ich spreche euch schon an
und habe ich nicht zwei Rosen das kann
doch nicht wahr sein oder wir haben eine
starke Landtagsfraktion insofern ich
nicht nur davon aus dass wir im Landtag
sein werden sondern da ist
Regierungsverantwortung drin in
Niedersachsen in welcher Konstellation
auch immer mutmaß in einer 3
Konstellation
haben
wieder eine Niederlage
werde die sieben sicherer am Ende fliegt
die FDP aus dem Landtag
was heißt das für Berlin
war der ampelinterne Konfrontationskurs
zu hart oder im Gegenteil nicht
ausreichend
Zeit dass man flächendeckende ganz
Deutschland erfährt was für eine
herausragende Politik wir in Berlin
machen und das setzt voraus dass wir
auch keinen Konflikt aus dem Weg gehen
es gibt eine wirklich internationale
nationale Aufgabe zurzeit die so noch
nie gegeben hat sondern 1945 und die
Menschen draußen die uns gewählt haben
haben auch das Anrecht dass wir das
seriös machen und jetzt hier nicht
kindergartenspielchen machen
erste liberale stellen die Ampel ganz in
Frage sie sei wie ein Mühlstein um den
Hals der FDP
im Herbst 2022 hat Entfremdung
eingesetzt wie soll es jetzt weitergehen
gute
[Musik]
Mitte Oktober vor dem Kongresszentrum in
Bonn ist Erstaunliches zu sehen
Atomkraft Befürworter aus der Wirtschaft
demonstrieren direkt neben Atomkraft
Gegnern der Adressat ihres Protestes ist
derselbe die grüne
[Musik]
drinnen ist bundesstellegierten
Konferenz die Grünen entstanden vor 40
Jahren aus der anti-akkb-bewegung jetzt
verlangt ein grüner Vizekanzler von
ihnen mehr Realitätssinn
[Musik]
schaut auf die Kraft die passiert die
entsteht wenn eine Partei sich nicht
parteilich kleintiert verhält längere
Atomlaufzeiten eine Zumutung für viele
grüne für manche junge vor allem aber
viele ältere habe ich selbst kann sich
eine befristete Verlängerung vorstellen
doch die Fraktionsführung ständig
dagegen Wochen lang ein Machtkampf
hinter den Kulissen
am Ende steht ein Kompromiss zur
Abstimmung zwischen regierungssaison und
grüner Geschichte
atomverlängerung nur bis April nur im
Notfall nur für zwei Meiler für viele
die absolute Schmerzgrenze
[Musik]
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde was der
Bundesvorstand vorgelegt hat das ist
eine Zumutung auch für mich persönlich
wir leben das Desaster der Atomenergie
schafft Atomenergie Sicherheit nein
niemand braucht die Atomenergie in
dieser ganzen Debatte geht es nicht um
Inhalte es geht einzig und allein darum
also in dieser öffentlichen Debatte
vermeintliche grüne Lebenslügen
aufzuzeigen
trotzdem die Delegierten Stimmen für
diesen Kompromiss
sie glauben der müsche auch für die FDP
gelten
wir haben jetzt ein einen großen Schritt
weil die Wirklichkeit das fordert hinter
uns gebracht da bin ich stolz und froh
drüber und damit ist der fachliche
Vorschlag von der Partei getragen und
abgelegt abgesegnet ich glaube heute
Abend ist deutlich geworden dieses ist
der letzte Schritt den wir mitgehen und
ich habe Hoffnung dass das hier
hinreichend klar und öffentlich
kommuniziert wurde
ansonsten war es die Zukunft springt
weiß man nicht aber ich glaube es ist
klar wenn die FDP das will muss sie sich
andere Koalitionspartner suchen
diese Hoffnung überlebt rund 72 Stunden
ein letzter Einigungsversuch im
Kanzleramt endet ergebnislos
dann zieht Kanzler Scholz die Reißleine
er beendet den monatelangen Atomstreit
mit einem Brief an die Minister bis
Mitte April schon genau drei Kraftwerke
länger laufen nicht nur zur Not sondern
auf jeden Fall
nachdem es etwas mühselig war eine
Verständigung herbeizuführen habe ich
die Möglichkeiten die das Grundgesetz
mir dazu gibt genutzt
Kanzler Machtwort jetzt also doch gegen
den Parteitagsbeschluss der Grünen einem
von ihnen platzt der Kragen
es wissen viele das mittlerweile die
Koalition in einem Zustand ist wo man
mit Erpressung durchkommt Olaf Scholz
hat eine Politik des Brechens von
Vereinbarung ist Nachtretens und des
nachverhandelns den Segen gegeben
am Tag nach dem Kanzler Machtwort muss
Habeck in die wöchentliche
Fraktionssitzung der Grünen
der Vizekanzler wirkt gelassen
das Machtwort von Scholz lenkt den
Grünen Ärger weg von ihm
also ich glaube nicht dass in der
Debatte gerade Robert Habeck das Problem
ist sondern ein Kanzler der auf einmal
mit einer Wasserpolitik die man
irgendwie von vor einigen Jahrzehnten
vielleicht so kennt agiert und das
verwundert mich ehrlich gesagt schon
lange verfahrene Situation wir sind
anders nicht rausgekommen nicht alle
werden zustimmen muss aber auch nicht
sein Hauptsache Stimmung genug zu tun
sie ist genauso gemacht als Kanzler
am Ende ja vielleicht ja aber es ist
verkauft nämlich in der Situation muss
man zu machen
das sollte nicht die gängeige Methode in
einer Koalition werden die sich ja in
die Hand versprochen hat dass wir Dinge
auch in der politischen Kultur anders
machen und da muss man anderen Stil
haben als diese öffentliche Streit bei
der akw-frage über Wochen also das Thema
Atomkraftwerke ist dann beendet im April
das beendet
wie oft kann ein Kanzlerin Machtwort
sprechen das kann er nicht sehr oft tun
vor allen Dingen er kann es in dieser
Form nicht oft tun vielleicht kann das
sogar gar nicht wiederholen die nächste
Stufe ist dann die Vertrauensfrage und
Franz Müntefering hat es ja mal ganz
richtig gesagt ein Bundeskanzler der zu
diesen Mitteln greifen muss gesteht
eigentlich zu dass die Koalition am Ende
ist und was sagt die FDP ihr
Fraktionschefin hatte das Mittel
Machtwort einige Wochen vorher noch
absurd und jetzt ich will sagen für die
Freien Demokraten dass wir diese
Entscheidung für die Bundesregierung
durch den Bundeskanzler ausdrücklich
begrüßen das war wichtig dass diese
Entscheidung jetzt gefallen ist am Ende
sagten beide Konfliktparteien wir können
mit dem Ergebnis gut leben was ein
bisschen komisch ist weil wenn wirklich
beide damit gut leben können würde man
denken dann hättet ihr die Einigung ja
auch selber finden können also ich
glaube hier war es eher ein Instrument
um
Gesichtswahrung für alle in einer
schwierigen Verhandlungssituation
schaffen zu können
also ist wirklich das letzte Wort
gesprochen manche liberale ist
entschlossen das Atomthema
weiterzutreiben
jetzt laufen sie erstmal bis April das
ist schon mal ein erster Schritt aber es
kommen ja weitere Winter und deshalb
muss man natürlich auch über eine
Verlängerung dann diskutieren es gibt
Stimmen aus ihrer Partei aus ihrer
Fraktion die sagen wir müssen dann auch
notwendigerweise ab nach April darüber
reden wer Stimmen hört muss ich selber
viele Fragen stellen
und deshalb kann ich nur für mich
sprechen wir haben für diesen Winter
richtige Entscheidungen getroffen und
die Bundesregierung wird auch für die
nächsten Winter angemessen und richtige
Entscheidungen treffen dazu gehört aber
nicht mehr die Frage einer
atomkraftverlängerung angemessen und
richtige Entscheidungen werden dann
getroffen werden
die SPD fördert weiter mit sich selbst
ihre Jugendorganisation trifft sich zum
Bundeskongress
auch parteicheflers Klingbeil ist
eingeladen
also eins zwei drei große Koalition
die freundliche selfie-stimmung trügt
Klingbeil hatte Monate zuvor Deutschland
zur Führungsmacht erklärt im Alleingang
ohne vorher den Rückhalt der Basis
einzuholen
jetzt macht sich bei vielen
Ärger Luft
wir stehen solidarisch an der Seite der
Ukraine ich glaube nicht dass wir das
als führungsmarkt tun sollten die Lehre
aus diesem Krieg muss sein dass wir vor
allem osteuropäischen Partner in auf
Augenhöhe begegnen ich glaube nicht und
ich bin der festen Überzeugung und werde
mich da auch mit allen Mitteln wehren
das ist richtig ist zu sagen wir sind
eine Führungsmacht oder wir sind
übernehmen Führungszeugnis ich halte
daran fest ich weiß dass euch das nicht
gefällt
die Jungsozialisten sind ein wachsender
Machtfaktor etwa jeder vierte
SPD-Bundestagsabgeordnete ist auch
jusomitglied viele hier sind genervt vom
ständigen Rücksicht nehmen wo bleiben
etwa Tempolimit und Vermögensabgabe die
Aussprache wird zur Abrechnung
der schwarz
en nur Kanzlerpartei sein heißt nicht
dem kannst du hinterherzulaufen als
Parteivorsitzender ist man auch immer
wohl ein bisschen Regierungssprecher des
Kanzlers aber für meinen Geschmack gehst
du etwas zu sehr in dieser Rolle auf
unsere Wählerin aber maximal klar
Bekannte von der SPD und damit von dir
weil wir diese Regierung anführen
eine Stunde stand Pauke nimmt Klingbeil
entgegen am Ende bleibt ihm nur um
Solidarität zu bitten mit dem Kanzler
und mit ihm selbst ich möchte nicht dass
wir abzählen wo ist die willy-brandt aus
SPD wo es die regierungsspd wo ist die
fraktions-spd wo sind die sehr Hämmer wo
sind die Netzwerke wo sind die Jusos die
wir genossen und genossen wir haben
diese Bundestagswahl gewonnen weil wir
eine SPD sind weil wir zusammen
gestanden haben
Klingbeil führt nach Hause mit der
Botschaft das bei den Jungen in der SPD
ampelfrust gewachsen ist
Anfang November geht der deutsche
Wirtschaftsminister auf große Reise nach
Singapur sein Ziel nicht weniger als
eine Neuausrichtung der
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen weg von China hin
zu neuen Märkten
diese Reise passt eben sehr gut in diese
Zeit dass wir mit einem starken
Wirtschaftsraum mit einem sehr
dynamischen Wirtschaftsraum auf sehr
hohe politischer und unternehmerischer
Ebene noch einmal die Gespräche
vertiefen
auf dem Programm steht unter anderem
eine große Wirtschaftskonferenz
begleitet wird habeg von rund 20
Unternehmen und ebenso vielen
Journalisten
an Bord ein Ritual
Hintergrundgespräch mit den Presseleuten
der Minister redet offen aber zitieren
darf man daraus nicht
[Musik]
seit Oktober hat die Ampelkoalition
keine Mehrheit mehr in den Umfragen auch
habecks persönliche Beliebtheit ist
deutlich gesunken
was bedeutet das für ihn
in den in den
Vorlagen die ich bekomme in den Analysen
die ich lese stehen alle möglichen
sachlichen Informationen dran zu
unternehmen zu Wirtschaftsdaten zu
Energieflüssen da steht nicht drin und
die Umfrage XY ist dafür oder dagegen
oder die Opposition mag es nicht und das
hat einen Sinn das ist da drin nicht
steht
Singapur eine Wirtschaftsmacht ein
Brückenkopf nach Asien
Habeck trifft Regierungsvertreter
unterzeichnet Handelsabkommen
besucht für die Fotografen einen
interaktiven Freizeitpark
das Programm eng getaktet in Habicht
reden taucht ein Motiv immer wieder auf
die multikrise aus Klimakollaps
weltkriegsgefahr Inflation dafür kein
Grund sein zu
verzagented and go into the fight love
the fight to the job besonders eingehen
widmet sich der Vizekanzler den
Vertretern der deutschen Wirtschaft etwa
bei einem Abend Empfang der Deutschen
Bank auf dem Dach des markantesten
Gebäudes
Lobbyismus auf 200 Metern Höhe
Harbeck wirbt für einen Handel jenseits
von China
Abhängigkeiten lösen auch das ist
Zeitenwende
wir haben 30 Jahre lang quasi diese
unpolitische Sicht auf China zum Prinzip
unserer Handelspolitik gemacht jetzt
gibt es eine extrem politische Sicht von
China auf China aber wir werden ein paar
Jahre brauchen um uns langsam daraus zu
arbeiten
[Musik]
auch der Bundeskanzler wird in Singapur
erwartet dessen China Politik hat
weitere Gräben offengelegt zwischen den
Koalitionären
Scholz war kurz zuvor nach China gereist
ein falsches Signal zur falschen Zeit
fanden FDP und Grüne und dann wollte der
Kanzler durchwinken dass der chinesische
Staatskonzern cosco sich in den
Hamburger Hafen einkauft sechs
Ministerien waren dagegen auch habe ich
am Ende wird die Beteiligung reduziert
ein mühsam erstrittener Kompromiss
monatelang setzt der Habig auf
harmoniere Torik jetzt in Singapur wird
er in einem Interview ungewöhnlich
deutlich
spricht von Sieg und Niederlage
innerhalb der Ampel
i think it's only have Messer half
victory in away I would have to for that
be investment of cosgo the great Chinese
shipping company in the port of Hamburg
[Musik]
wieder in der zweiten Reihe
elf Monate nach Ampelstart 10.000
Kilometer von Berlin entfernt ist die
Spitze einer Koalition zu besichtigen
abgekämpft in vielen Fragen uneins das
Jahr hat Spuren hinterlassen
[Musik]
Deutschland nach neun Monaten
ukrainekrieg seine Rolle in der Welt im
Wandel die Gasspeicher gefüllt die
Energiepreise auf Rekordhoch Inflation
quer das Land der Mindestlohn erhöht
Preis Bremsen beschlossen
reicht das
die Ampel wollte Richtung Fortschritt
Steuern und ist jetzt auf krisenkurs
gezwungen
hier wird gerade Geschichte geschrieben
das ist gerade eine historische Phase es
geht gerade um
existenzielle Weichenstellungen in
diesem Land die fragen Sie mich in zwei
Jahren noch mal wie ich auf diese Phase
zurückgekommen aber gerade gucke ich das
schon mit sehr großer Ehrfurcht drauf
und habe für jeden Tag für jede
Entscheidung die manche trifft großen
Respekt haben einen enormen
modernisierungsstaube Bildung bei der
Digitalisierung bei der
Verkehrsinfrastruktur bei den sauberen
Technologien die unseren zukünftigen
Wohlstand sichern sollen ohne
klimaschädlich zu sein das muss jetzt
aufgearbeitet werden und das sind große
Anstrengungen am besten ist es doch
weniger stark auf die Umfragen zu
schauen weniger stark auf die
persönlichkeitswerte zu schauen weniger
stark über die öffentliche Arbeit zu
kommen sondern sich gegenseitig etwas zu
gönnen und hinter den Kulissen die
Sachen gut vorzubereiten gucken ob es
gelingt fängt erst an wir haben noch ein
paar Jahre
die Ampel eine Koalition im
Ausnahmezustand
alle Beteiligten Ahnen einen normalen
Zustand wird es vielleicht nie wieder
geben
[Musik]